[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israels heute gibt es ein herzhaftes
rezept eine gute rezept idee zu
silvester oder zu allen veranstaltungen
die so bei euch noch anstehen wir werden
nämlich oder ich werde heute politik
machen dazu etwas kartoffelstampf oder
kartoffelpüree
das überlege ich mir noch und krautsalat
und warum ist es eine gute silvester
idee denn das ganze ist ein kraut wieder
ihr könnt wirklich gleich eine große
menge zu bereiten
davon werden viele menschen satt und man
kann super vorbereiten wenn man es
richtig planen also gestern hat mir noch
die sarah erzählt aus unserem team das
die letztes jahr zu silvester auch
politik gemacht haben und dann haben sie
es halt so blöd geteilt dass sie
praktisch nachts um drei auf stehen
haben müssen um das fleisch verrückten
ja das ist natürlich noch nicht ganz so
praktisch wollen wenn man diese
leicester nach durch machen will
deswegen plant am besten so dass ihr
morgens das gericht vorbereitet so wie
ich jetzt und am nachmittag könnte es
dann zu rufen und dann ist es fertig am
abend können das dann egal wann einfach
nur noch aufwärmen und das ist dann
wirklich perfekt ich brauche hier
wirklich nicht viele zutaten fürs
politik braucht ihr einfach ein bisschen
rindfleisch und verschiedene gewürze ich
zeig euch mal für das pult lief nämlich
etwas mehr als zwei kilo kinder braten
ich habe 50 gramm butter schmalz vier
zwiebeln
ich habe ich balsamico-essig 50 gramm
400 gramm fleischbrühe 4 knoblauchzehen
100 gramm tomatenmark etwas dijon sind
und hier noch die gewürze ich nehme sap
hier vier wacholderbeeren einen
teelöffel senf einen teelöffel salz
etwas chili eine prise braunen zucker
einen teelöffel süßes paprikapulver und
ein lorbeerblatt
dafür nimmt jetzt ein gefäß was sowohl
auf dem herz funktioniert als auch im
backofen ich nehme jetzt meinem
gusseisernen topf und zwar den topf
allem heißt übrigens meine mama
falls ihr das gusseisen video noch nicht
gesehen habt schaut auf jeden fall mal
rein
da habe ich der murat gemeinsamen jobs
nämlich gezeigt wie die großen töpfe
hergestellt werden und das ist echt also
das video müsst ihr euch wirklich mal
anschauen unserem großen topf den
benutze ich wirklich für sachen also für
gerichte die ich entweder auf dem herd
kochen und wirklich schön lange auch
kochen möchte oder eben im backofen und
da kann man einfach schön hin und her
switchen weil bei töpfen ist oft das
problem dass sie einfach nicht dick war
nicht sind unseren gusseisen topf der
held einfach die temperatur und nimmt
sie langsam an gibt es auch langsam
wieder ansgar gut ab und hält auch
wirklich für mehrere stunden warm und so
machen wir das jetzt also ich werde
jetzt hier den topf erstmal erwärmen und
das mache ich jetzt nicht gleich auf
volle pulle sondern wirklich langsam
erst mal auf stufe 5 6 und dann auf 7
muss dann auch reichen auf 8 muss ich
wahrscheinlich gar nicht und töpfe und
pfannen niemals leer jetzt das heißt
hier schon mal das butterschmalz mit
rein geben damit einfach nicht von sich
aus überhitzt es war kein teurer töpfe
pfannen und töpfe wirklich sehr gut
schon die knoblauchzehen die werde ich
jetzt auch einfach nur kurz halbieren
doch das war erst mal schon das warte
ich noch kurz aufs butterschmalz und bis
der topf heben schönheit ist
[Musik]
der top-liste teils das fett ist auch
heißt was ganz wichtig ist dass das
fleisch nicht eiskalt ist also ihr
solltet es wirklich mindestens eine
stunde besser zwei vorher aus dem
kühlschrank nehmen damit raumtemperatur
annimmt damit das fleisch nicht so wird
denn wenn ihr eiskaltes fleisch in einem
ganz heißen topf legt dann zieht sich
zusammen mit ganz c also wirklich schön
raunten im rat vor annehmen lassen und
jetzt von allen seiten scharf anbraten
ich trete ist aber auch zwischendurch
sind schwierig bei so einem großen platz
steht aber als
[Musik]
das habe ich fleisch rausgeholt denn
jetzt gebe ich das restliche butter
schmalz mit dem topf passt auch kurz
schmelzen und dann kommen hier direkt
die zwiebel und knoblauchzehen rein und
werden auch angebraten
so bekommt alles schöne röstaromen
zwiebel und knoblauchzehen since
angebraten hier gebe ich hier etwas
tomatenmark dazu kann auch kurz mit
angebrachten werden dann direkt mit dem
essig ablöschen
am besten aus dem weg gehen denn es sich
wenn der verdammt das tut schon ein
bisschen weh die fleischbrühe macht dazu
muss jetzt einfach alle anderen zutaten
rein also wirklich alle gewürze dazu
will ich es nicht gerne scharf mögt dann
lass den chili wegnimmt nur
paprikapulver jetzt kommt auch noch mit
rein
schön früher und da lege ich jetzt das
fleisch weder dazu stellt den herd aus
denn meine arbeit ist jetzt erst mal
getan
ich verwende das fleisch erst mal noch
kurz das heißt es komplett bedeckt jetzt
kommt hier der deckel drauf und dann
kommt das fleisch in den backofen bei
120 grad ober unterhitze und sport dann
darin für etwa sechs bis acht stunden
danach wird's wirklich richtig zeit nach
etwa drei stunden gucke ich mal rein
wenn du das fleisch noch einmal und nach
etwa sechs stunden sollte mein fleisch
eigentlich schon fertig sein wenn nicht
dann wirklich acht stunden und so können
sie das wirklich prima vorbereiten und
später hab jetzt gleich mache ich noch
den krautsalat und später kümmere ich
mich noch um die kartoffel
also kurz bevor dieses gericht fertig
wird
[Musik]
jetzt gibt den krautsalat ich habe jetzt
hier einen weißkohl und einen rotkohl
sieht beides sehr unscheinbar aus aber
beide wiegen jeweils drei kilo also
schon schon der große menge kann ich nur
die hälfte zu bereiten das dürfte auch
ausreichen dann nehme ich noch zwei rote
zwiebel ich habe es salz braunen zucker
und pfeffer etwas zitronensaft
sonnenblumenöl und apfelessig und jetzt
trage ich handschuhe denn ich möchte
keine rose abhängen blauen hände
daher nehme ich dir jetzt aber ich bin
echt stolz auf mich denn am anfang
meiner youtube zeit hatte ich echt oft
handschuhe an weil ich auch so fleisch
nicht so wirklich anfassen wollte und
jetzt hallo keine atome nur wenn ich
keine verfärbungen will nächste patient
wieder blaukraut bleibt blaukraut und
brautkleid bleibt blaukraut brautkleid
hamann ich kann nicht mal ein anfang
braun brautkleid bleibt brautkleid und
blaukraut bleibt blaukraut bleibt
blaukraut und brautkleid bleibt programm
und das ist jetzt ganz schnell
brautkleid bleibt auch kein ergebnis
es tut mir leid das geht nicht
brautkleid bleibt blaukraut
hier entfällt ich hätte das machen wir
später entferne ich jetzt die äußeren
blätter
wir üben noch einmalig über in meinem
inneren immer im kopf bin ich nochmal
und später seien die äußeren blätter die
entferne ich jetzt
und jetzt wird der kohl halbiert
[Musik]
sie hat jetzt auch den strunk entfernen
und jetzt könnt ihr entweder mit einem
messer den kohl ganz fein schneiden
das wirklich super mega find es ist ganz
ganz dünn dauert aber ein bisschen lange
route nehmt euch ein von der
küchenmaschine und raspelt es ganz fein
oder nimmt sohn alles schneiden
ich mache das jetzt alles schneider ich
selbst da direkt mein blech darunter
dann kann ich das da direkt reinfallen
lassen
so habe ich auch letztes jahr für meine
mama über zehn kilo kohl verarbeitet und
jetzt dann eingelegt das ist lecker so
heißt es bei uns die türkisch hier rein
und dann ganz ganz dünn schneiden ist
jetzt direkt ist leicht runter ich mache
jetzt hier mal so 2 mm am anfang brauche
ich noch keinen finger schutz
[Musik]
vielleicht als kleinen tipp damit ihr
wirklich keine reste habt ich habe das
jetzt hier schon vor portioniert legt
flach so jetzt auf den boden und tut es
jetzt erst nach vorne und hinten richtig
schön gerade schneiden als ich hier die
kann sich hier anlegen und dann könnt
ihr hier hin nämlich den fingern schutz
anlegen und wirklich schön weiter
schneiden bis zum ende
die zwiebeln die halt bier ich jetzt so
habe ich eine schöne gerade schnittkante
kann dir jetzt auch noch kurz schneiden
und das ganze hat jetzt wirklich weniger
als fünf minuten gedauert
fünf minuten hat es gedauert aber
wirklich weniger als 10 das heißt ihr
seid echt super schnell fertig
[Musik]
kann ich schon direkt die krone
halbieren und das brett weg stellen
jetzt erstmal nicht mehr und geht jetzt
alles hier in dieser schale rhein direkt
zu den zwiebeln
es lief auch einfach zwiebel salat man
rote zwiebel zitrone petersilie und so
mag es sich bomben gewürzt und jetzt
kommen hier alle gewürze rein das öl der
essig salz pfeffer zucker senf
das kann ich erst mal so die zwiebel ein
bisschen verkneten
und jetzt kommt der kohl dazu und das
ganze wird dann für mindestens fünf
minuten geknetet so wird der kohl auch
richtig schön weich und nimmt vor allem
auch den geschmack an
und ich kenne jetzt immer ein bisschen
hole dann merkt wohl dazu also das ist
jetzt etwas heller arbeit
man kann bestimmt auch einfach den
knethaken nehmen oder den karriere war
sie diesen flach hörer aber ich mache
das nicht weil ich jetzt schon
angefangen haben
[Musik]
und ich habe jetzt hier bereits meine
mehlig kochende kartoffeln aufgesetzt
damit die gleich fertig sind und zwar
habe ich den bevor ich sie gekocht habe
rundherum ein geschlitzt damit ich sie
gleich besser schälen kann
das nehme ich hier das fleisch heraus
guck mal das zerfällt er schon von
alleine
ich kann es jetzt mit den zwei gabeln
nun wirklich schön auseinander zog wo
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt das fleisch richtig
schön zart und hier noch die brühe die
benutze ich natürlich weiter ist noch
warm aber nicht mehr heißt okay und ich
streiche das jetzt hier durch die
fleißige ließe so habe ich nämlich
gleich die fleischbrühe aber eben keine
stückchen mehr
hier seht ihr auch ganz schön das
lorbeerblatt es bleibt es hier auch mit
draußen also alles was ich nicht in der
soße haben will landet er sieht diesen
hat jetzt auch schön zerkleinert und
dadurch würde ich so jetzt auch gleich
schon sehen ich und daraus mache ich
jetzt noch eine braune soße ihr könnt
sie entweder so lassen oder gerne noch
champignons und steinpilze dazu geben
ich mache so ein bisschen nach art
trocken auf also noch keine chance mit
dazu ich zeige ich mir eben die saucen
zutaten für die soße nehme ich etwas
butter und mehl meine brühe
hier habe ich noch steinpilze die habe
ich bereits im wasser eingelegt
cornichons salz und pfeffer etwas
sojasauce und wenn ihr wollt gerne noch
champignons die butter kommt jetzt hier
in den gusseisernen britta erzählt nach
viel butter aus ich weiß ob es hat auch
eine große menge highstreet und diez
erlasse ich jetzt hier das machen wir
erst mal eine mehlschwitze
hier kommt jetzt das mehl dazu ich will
jetzt einfach mit angebraten für etwa
ein bis zwei minuten
[Musik]
wenn es dann so schön schäumt kommt
jetzt die brauereien richtig schön
rühren
[Musik]
hier gebe ich jetzt noch die aufgeweicht
und steinpilze mit dazu direkt mit dem
wasser
das hat nämlich jetzt auch einen ganz
tollen geschmack und dann sojasauce zum
abrunden
klasse dass hier einmal aufkochen und
gleicht köchin und kann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die champignons
und die kollisions in feinen streifen 14
12 scheiben schneiden
es gebe ich hier das gemüse rhein statt
so der moment wurde mourad sagen würde
das gemüse können wir uns sparen aber
kommen gemüse das muss sein wir können
es aber auch wie gesagt weglassen
schmeckt so schon genial und ich mag vor
allem dieses säure aus dem kommissions
ich lecker kurz einrühren und mit etwas
salz würzen
ein bisschen salz fehlt noch ich glaube
ich packte jetzt noch ein paar
pfefferkörner betreiben
das rundet alles normal ich hab mir gar
kein werk war
ich wollte dir einfach nur meine gefühle
zu zeigen
tatsache bleibt den ganzen pfeffer hier
denn ich habe ihnen der müllmenge sein
glaube ich den aus der mail daraus man
nehme zwei teelöffel ganze pfefferkörner
pfefferkörner und ging es dann jetzt
habe ich den euro dollar und fahrt
rechnen
okay die soße lasse ich jetzt hier ein
bisschen köcheln die kartoffeln sind mit
sicherheit auch schon durch die werde
ich kalt abschrecken noch ein paar
knoblauchzehen schälen und dann wird
fertig angerichtet sobald es hier
nämlich geköchelt hat gebe ich das
fleisch reihen und schalt dem herd aus
und so kann man es wirklich auch super
vorbereiten und dann einfach nur noch
erwärmen aber das fleisch würde ich
jetzt einfach nicht mehr mit kochen denn
das ist ja schon richtig schön fahrt
also schnell noch mal alles fertig
hier das fleisch rein damit das schöne
zarte fleisch auch nicht austrocknet
jetzt haben wir extrem riesenpot okay
jetzt kommt wieder die frage für wie
viel personen reicht es für 6 j oder für
zwölf frauen also jetzt mal ganz ehrlich
das wird für mich und meine freunde
freundinnen
da würden wir glaube ich 20 personen
davon essen was ich bei cnet aber schon
eine große menge spaß sagt studer als
man dazu der viel und gut essen kann
ach komm zehn kommen da 10 gleich kann
es schon davon essen oder mit snacks und
desserts
ok also ich meine der ganze prozess voll
perfekt dass es also bereits und hier
habe ich jetzt schon die kartoffeln
geschält da kann ich jetzt die butter
hier in einem topf zerlassen dann
nämlich gerade den topf den ich gerade
zum kochen hatte
hiermit und dann habe ich hier schon die
knoblauchzehen fein geschnitten machen
wir so einen schönen knoblauch
kartoffelstampf ich mache das hier
drüben dann seht ihr das nämlich besser
jetzt schön die knoblauchzehen anbraten
das reicht jetzt von lecker und das
kartoffelpüree das würde ich schon
frisch machen also das finde ich hier
der folge man falsch machen
oder einfach puls bi server bistro dazu
[Musik]
das jetzt ein bisschen bräunen
da kommt jetzt die milch dazu und den
kartoffeln und dann kann ich dir jetzt
schön zerstampfen mit salz pfeffer und
etwas muskat würzen und fertig
[Musik]
ich verstand dass jetzt nur ein bisschen
und damit einfach noch ein bisschen
stück ich bleibt so mag ich ganz gerne
es ist doch ganz durch püriert es muss
dann wenn man älter sind und die dritten
[Musik]
also eigentlich sollte jetzt der murat
probieren der murat hat aber leider die
männer grippe berater auch mit der
kamera zu schauen wie war eigentlich
schon gut eingestellt darf später
probieren hier ist murat wiesbaden
beschwert euch bei den beiden menschen
können das den anvertrauen ja doch oder
war dieser schon jetzt sind wir beide
drauf ich glaube man hat mir sorgen in
der türkei eine woche ok ich unsere
stadt ist also heute gibt's pult beef
mit kartoffelpüree
die fünf euro in unsere in unserer
klasse
kameramann ist okay jetzt hat das
vergnügen das zu probieren
jetzt aber hier das wasser stammt als
kartoffelpüree habe ich jetzt einen
gusseisernen topf denn da kann man es
auch schön warm halten da hängt ja auch
die werbe als oliver j ich würde das
jetzt glaub ich doch einfach mal ich
finde es richtig dass gleich sogar
bislang natürlich ist eine kleine mulde
das ist richtig gut aus ich hoffe dass
es dann mal den ganzen tag darauf
gewartet und sagte das war geblendet vor
der kamera probierte davon ausprobieren
ganz ehrlich ich sehe noch kein graben
krautsalat krass das habe ich jetzt gar
nicht mal so gesehen ist das so pink
wurde
wir haben rotkohl und weißkohl macht
vorherrsche deine augen ich habe geguckt
dass das bild scharf ist okay das
hauptproblem das bin ich mal gespannt
ja ja also diese auf die türkische
drehtüren war ich nie im deutschen
fernsehen zu sehen
das ist ja und dann ist knoblauch
kartoffelpüree also mir schmeckt die
chance nicht rausholen was ich mega gut
findet auch bei burger immer die zutat
hatte sich ziemlich nah das ist
schmerzhaft und ich bin auf jeden fall
auch ein jumbo fans so also auch pizza
champignons und also der frage ist nicht
so bei diesem thema was ist trifft genau
meinen geschmack muss und wie gesagt ihr
könnt super gut vorbereiten auch den
kauz salat vor allem ein guter
krautsalat etwas für volkan alles andere
aber ansonsten kann jetzt hier das ganze
team davon essen was meint ihr bade
morath w für personen reicht das ja gut
und welche art von person gesehen und
erlebt kommt man oft schon grad effekte
jetzt und es macht spaß sich um schulen
könnten dieses kleine teller august
haben in diesem tempo portion also wenn
ihr so kleine portionen macht dann
reicht das auch für 30 tage automatisch
geschieht ja es ist gut dass dieser rat
es ist nicht sein aber du bist an
reduktion okay also morath kriegt jetzt
auch noch der patient der sich jetzt die
sterne portion sternekoch passion nach
sternekoch ganz ehrlich dann wären es 40
portionen minimum mindestens 50 das war
genau auf was weiß ich was wäre ein
gebratener
[Musik]
gebratene wie heißt es knoblauchzehe
unter kartoffelpüree haube an sortierte
rindfleisch mit krautsalat und dieses
rezept könnt ihr gerne nachmachen auf
celtics - blog.de stets noch mal ich
finde es echt cooles silvester gericht
man bereite jetzt vor und dann kann voll
die jungs und mädels reinhauen jameda
und ich denken kann war machen so auch
irgendwie wir wollten ja gut dass gerade
das sterne innerhalb von zwei sekunden
vergessen warum nicht mal genossen es
war
du musst einfach wirklich viel spaß
machen und bis zum nächsten mal kann es
sein dass es in diesem jahr war kann es
guten rutsch guten rutsch um was du ich
bin ja macht auf jeden fall mal nach das
kann man ja das macht er jeden tag jeden
tag von morgens bis abends ohne
halterung jack russel ja ohne wir haben
gerade ein auto gedreht und neulich so
zwei stunden ohne absetzen weist der
niedersachen ja nicht sein
[Musik]